dear Nintendo I've been a massive fan of
Nintendo since I was a child my friends
would often have me over to play games
like gauntlet on the NES or Jurassic
Park on the Super NES and back then we'd
marvel at the impressive graphics or we
chatter about the expectations for
whatever they were developing next I
vividly remember my dad bringing home a
gameboy and a Tetris cartridge which
actually gave me a genuine interest in
puzzle games as a collector I've gotten
my hands on such items as old
promotional VHS tape an absurd amount of
Nintendo Power magazines a clinically
unhealthy overabundance of amiibo and of
course a huge collection of games from
every major Nintendo console most
notably about half of the games released
for the Nintendo 64 complete with box
game and manual there's a major
difference between being a fan of
something and being a blind fan you're
not going to see me screaming in the
comment section declaring that the Wii U
is the best system ever made or that the
Virtual Boy was the most misunderstood
product known to man that thing was
complete utter I'm the kind of fan
that gets ecstatic when something I love
is done right and done with care but I'm
not blind to the problems with the
looming release of the switch I wanted
to make this video as an open letter of
sorts to Nintendo or an open video I
don't know what to say it's 2017 what's
going on I've heard many of the things
I'm about to discuss echoed by close
personal friends and I hope that if
Nintendo is watching they take this to
heart let's talk a little about
Nintendo's history starting with their
first major success the NES was a
groundbreaking machine after the great
video game crash of 1983 the NES
successfully changed the business and
made home gaming a staple of the future
this whopping behemoth sold over 61
million units worldwide and with
classics like Super Mario Brothers The
Legend of Zelda Metroid castlevania and
mega
man - under its belt it's easy to see
why no one in the industry saw this
thing coming the innovations made by
this console are still being felt today
with the follow-up the Super NES
Nintendo continued to dominate the video
game scene despite competition from the
Sega Genesis the Super Nintendo sold
over 49 million units while the Genesis
moved about 30 million the Super
Nintendo built upon what the original
Nintendo started providing a mostly
similar game experience while enhancing
the graphics and sound and adding a few
new buttons to the controller to this
day the SNES controller is considered by
many to be one of the most revolutionary
ever created it's design is still being
imitated it wasn't until the Nintendo 64
that the company really felt the heat
from a competitor the Sony PlayStation
sold an astounding 102 million units
while the 64 settled for just over 32
million Sony used disc media which
offered considerably more space and
Nintendo stuck with cartridges stating
with this limited load time despite how
revolutionary 2m6 before really was in
hindsight this loss seemed to confuse
Nintendo for some time their follow up
the Gamecube might just be the only time
in history that Nintendo has attempted
to go with the flow so to speak creating
a device similar in ability and
performance as the ps2 and Xbox then it
seems the company became obsessed with
discovering the next big thing the D s
was a huge success to them selling a
whopping 154 million units so it's no
real surprise
ever since then their innovations with
the Wii motion controls and the Wii U
Touch gamepad have placed a focus more
on the consoles themselves than the
games while the NES SNES and n64 are all
revolutionary systems that change the
industry what do we remember the most
about them was it the first time you
use the controller I'm betting your best
memory with those systems involved the
game when I think of the Super Nintendo
I think of Donkey Kong Country the
amazing soundtrack and the fun
challenges when I think of the NES I
think of the first time I flew in Super
Mario Brothers 3 when I think of the n64
I remember late night Goldeneye parties
that lasted until 5 a.m. and running
around high role in the ocarina of time
even into the Gamecube era underrated
titles like Eternal Darkness or Beyond
Good and Evil stand out absolute
classics like Metroid Prime or rogue
leader were some of the best games I'd
ever played anyone who loves being
creative should always focus on being
innovative I'm certainly not suggesting
that Nintendo just become a conveyor
belt turning out games that the masses
want forgetting about being
revolutionary what I'd love to see
however is for Nintendo to take that
vision that they've so wonderfully
incorporated into their Hardware the
consoles and apply it to their games
instead the console itself is always
important of course but at the end of
the day it's the games that sell the
console for instance despite being
intensely loyal to Nintendo in the 90s I
bought a PlayStation for one specific
reason a little game called
Metal Gear Solid I mean the Wii U
had so many great ideas and a few
amazing titles like Bayonetta 2 Pikmin 3
and of course Super Smash Brothers but
even for that game the majority still
prefer to play it with the GameCube
controller and Nintendo obviously knows
that since they offered the Gamecube
adapter as an option what does that tell
you Minh Tendo when you focus on the
industry as a whole
video game development has blown away
all expectations I ever had as a kid
graphics sound design and the overall
presentation of modern games was like a
distant dream in the 80s and 90s
it's unbelievable what games can do
today this is one of the reasons though
why it's so difficult to truly impress
any more this is also another reason
Nintendo has
focus so much on making innovations with
its hardware instead if you can't while
them with the graphics you might as well
blow their socks off with something like
motion control right yeah oh yeah no in
regards to graphics though the graphical
jump from Super Nintendo to Nintendo 64
is still the most impactful I've ever
seen
going from Super Mario World which in
its own right is a fantastic game to
seeing Mario's face bounce onto screen
and glorious 3d was jaw-dropping but
today after genius games like The Last
of Us graphics are expected to be
incredible now so Nintendo can no longer
rely on that to impress us ever since
their decision to limit the weeds of
standard-definition they've essentially
given up on wowing us visually and focus
more on being innovative but is
Nintendo's past really as perfect as my
hazy 90s goggles think it's always
difficult to separate yourself from
nostalgia when looking into the past
especially with something like Nintendo
obviously when I look back I attribute
fond memories of playing those games
with friends and I get warm fuzzy
feelings about that but truthfully
Nintendo's failings have always been
clear to me even when I've been one of
their biggest supporters for example the
Wii was financially successful yes but
it catered to children far too much
alienating Nintendo's lifelong fans by
releasing a slew of gimmicky party games
and baby games the 64 Double Dee yeah
you said Double Dee it means yes Double
Dee yeah this was an add-on to the n64
to introduce disc based media which
ended up only being available in Japan
never seeing the light of day anywhere
else
Nintendo filing copyright strikes
against many youtubers who were
operating well within their rights it's
just wrong and of course already
mentioned the Virtual Boy was the
biggest disaster ever there's
really no way around that one
and what I view as the worst mistake the
company has ever made not continuing its
partnership with rare where rare where
is responsible for some of the greatest
games ever made and they all just so
happen to be on Nintendo consoles
Battletoads snake rattle and rolls the
Donkey Kong Country trilogy killer
instinct blast core Goldeneye 64 Diddy
Kong Racing
banjo-kazooie banjo-tooie jet force
Gemini Donkey Kong 64 perfect dark
Conker's Bad Fur Day and starfox
adventures they're widely considered one
of the best video game developers of the
90s and many of their titles
specifically Goldeneye completely
changed the industry forever one could
even argue that it's unofficial
successor Perfect Dark was even better
but for whoever the knows why
Nintendo decided not to continue working
with rareware after starfox adventures
and Microsoft acquired the company since
then rare has done well let's just say
it hasn't been the same leaving rare
behind was the worst decision Nintendo
has ever made and since then their focus
has gone from crafting incredible games
to creating the next big thing so with
all this in mind what do I want to see
out of the upcoming switch console game
take the innovation that you're so known
for Nintendo and apply it to your game
make games your fans want a new metroid
prime that isn't this find ways to make
it easier for third-party developers to
create games for your system so that
they feel comfortable working with you
the Wii U was so vastly different from
the ps4 and Xbox one that to create a
game for the you meant changing so much
of the original code it's good to be
different but not to be so different
that you completely alienate everyone
from working with you focus on
incredible niche titles
think about it games like earthbound The
Secret of Mana or even the Harvest Moon
series have been immensely popular in
small circles for ages
the Wii U completely abandoned Natsu
maze fun farming simulator and a
lackluster mobile game was released
instead there are so many underrated
titles you could incorporate into your
library with a definite focus on
creating incredible games and with
Nintendo's vast array of famous
characters at its disposal the
opportunities are endless
I've already pre-ordered my switch and
it's my genuine hope that this console
can do what Nintendo seems to have
forgotten about since the Gamecube ended
its run
remember the fans the ones who've been
there since the beginning the one who
still read old Nintendo Power magazine
the ones who still host retro game
nights with their friends the ones who
remember the glory days with love Chris
Stockman PS thank you very much for
watching you guys are the best if you
liked this you can click right here and
get steppen eyes
[Music]
[Applause]